there's a lot of parallels between  bodybuilding and business the business  needs to be balanced but your skill set  doesn't need to be your whole body would  be a business like what you are good at  you should do more of right but your  body has to be balanced so you actually  start in Reverse so I train my  weaknesses to strongest parts so that  I'm freshest when I'm doing my things  that I need the most work on and then I  am most tired and fatigued on the stuff  that I'm already really good at I flip  that I do more volume on the stuff that  I'm weakest at versus the stuff I'm  strong at and I do it more frequently in  the beginning you got to be decent at  everything and that's why it's so hard  but then once you get up a certain level  of Leverage then it doesn't matter  because then you can hire other people  for your deficiencies